(upbeat music)
- Today we're checking out not one,
but two brand new gimbals from DJI.
This is the RS 2,
and we've also got
the RSC 2.
So we're gonna first start with the RS 2
because I've actually unboxed this
and I've been using it
on a few shoots already.
Then we will check out the RSC 2
and then we'll go outside
and test both of them out.
The RS 2 is the most powerful,
small size handheld stabilizer
that DJI has developed yet.
It is significantly
lighter than the Ronin-S,
but it's still powerful
enough for larger setups
and even medium sized cinema cameras.
I have actually been using
this for a little bit
before I sat down to make this video,
and we have been incredibly
impressed with it.
I love that it has a built-in touchscreen,
so you can use this to adjust settings
and it displays a live camera
view when using ActiveTrack.
This does require using
the RavenEye Image Transmission System.
This lets you wirelessly
transmit to your phone.
It'll give you a 1080p view
and a transmission up to a 100 meters.
Set up and balance on this thing
has actually been really seamless.
It has this new dual
layer quick-release plates
that you can set up quickly
without having to rebalance
every single time.
These little fine tuning
adjustment knobs are so amazing
for getting precise balance.
Before you would always be
nudging things here and there,
and then you'd go a little bit too far,
you'd mess everything up,
and then all of your hard
work of trying to balance
just goes right out the window.
There's also some really cool accessories
that you can get for this
to attach to car mounts,
jibs, and even sliders.
I've always loved the
built-in creative functions,
and this also includes
some like Time Tunnel,
Motionlapse, Timelapse,
panorama, and more of which you can find
right on the touchscreen.
You can get up to 12 hours of battery life
and it supports 24 watt fast charging.
So in just an hour and a half,
you can get a full charge.
This is pretty impressive,
considering the size and
weight of the battery
has been reduced by about 50%.
But the other thing that I love about this
is its a little carrying case.
This is so small, so compact,
that you can break this
down and fit everything
that you need right in here.
Now let's unbox the RSC 2.
Here we go.
So this is a pre-release packaging,
obviously it's not gonna
have this taped on it.
(knife scraping the box)
(gasps)
It has a carrying case.
It's, yes!
Oh, look at this.
It's like the same style.
I think it's basically the same case.
Look at that.
(zipper grinds)
This looks like a transformer.
(gimbal scraping)
I need to figure some things
out before we continue.
So the RS 2 is a more
entry level stabilizer
that has a new foldable design.
So you can transform it into
six different configurations
for various shootings scenarios
and for convenient storage.
There's upright, flashlight,
portrait, under sling,
briefcase, and storage.
There's a built-in front
dial right above the trigger.
So this lets you adjust the
camera's focus when paired
with a focus motor.
This also has the same dual
layer quick-release plates,
like the RS 2 that works with
Manfrotto and Arca-Swiss.
There's a new mechanical
three axis lock as well.
It has a built-in one inch OLED screen
to check gimbal status or adjust settings.
You can get up to 14 hours of battery life
with the two built-in
18,650 cell batteries
that are 3,500 milligrams each.
This has 18 watt fast
charging and will fully charge
in about an hour and a
half, and 80% in one hour.
Both of these have DJI's new
Titan Stabilization Algorithm,
which is their next gen stabilizing tech
to get even smoother shots.
There's also a super smooth
function that can be activated
for increased motor capacity and torque
for even more stable shots,
even when using a hundred
millimeter equivalent
focal length blends.
So now that we have all
of that out of the way,
let's get both of them side by side
and just take a little look.
First of all, this is obviously
made for higher end cameras.
You can get a much higher payload on this.
The red and the carbon fiber
finish on this looks so good.
You could obviously tell
if this is well equipped
for a larger camera because
you have so much more space
compared to this one.
So when you're kinda deciding
on which one you're gonna get,
it really does depend on, first
of all, what's your budget
and what kind of camera
are you gonna be putting
on this thing?
Honestly, for us, I feel
like most of the time,
this is kind of our setup.
But what I like so much about this
is being able to fine
tune your adjustments.
So there's these little knobs right here,
as you can see when you turn
this knob, the plate moves,
and this will let you get very,
very fine tuned adjustments
to make sure you're
getting the most stable
and perfectly even.
So here they are.
Let's take them out for a test.
(upbeat music)
Do you think I look cool?
I mean, I'm wearing two patterns of camo
and some really cool cheetah shoes.
Honestly, I would be friends with myself.
So this is the first time that
we're bringing them outside.
And this one is definitely heavier.
I really love how light this is
and I can just easily manipulate it.
And this one, we actually have
hooked up to the RavenEye.
We have ActiveTrack already set up.
This will also send a signal to my phone
when I do have it
connected to the RavenEye.
But it's cool because this
is actually a touch screen.
The other difference between the two
is the RS 2 does have a touch screen,
and the other one does not.
It has a very small display screen,
which will still let you view settings,
but you can't touch to control.
And then here is the RSC 2.
I am gonna be gonna a
trip for the first time
in seven months.
So I'm gonna take this one with me
because this one does fold down
to a really nice little
storage contraption.
I can't figure out the
words that I wanna say.
It folds down to be small.
This one actually folds
down to be pretty small too,
but I can't take both.
Tyler, what if I take RSC 2,
you take RC 2,
and you can get some
cool shots of your kiddy,
some Ronan cat and
whatever other adventures
you might get into over the weekend.
Cool, weekend, Ronan, fun, commence.
(upbeat music starts)
(upbeat music continues)
(light melodic music)
(soft upbeat music)
Made it to Maryland.
Tyler just sent me some
of the stuff that he shot
while he was out with RS
2, and I have the RSC 2.
And we're gonna go out and get some shots,
and hopefully we can make Tyler proud
because he shot some really cool content.
Are you ready, Jen?
- [Jen] Yeah.
- Let's go.
(soft upbeat music)
Thank you guys so much
for watching this video.
I hope that you enjoyed it.
Lemme know if you guys
have any other questions.
We will be in the
comments answering those.
And if you wanna get any
more information about them,
other than what I've
showed you in this video,
because there's so much more
that I didn't get a chance to cover,
there will be links in the description.
So you guys can go check it out.
I do plan on doing a followup video
and a lot of the stuff that I do shoot
in a lot of our daily videos,
we do use the DGI Ronin.
So I'm very excited to test these out
and you will see these in
action in many future videos.
So with that being said, I
have nothing else to say.
End!
(soft upbeat music)